[Музика]
Привіт усім і ласкаво просимо назад до
сьогоднішнього уроку англійської мови, наша тема: хм,
здається, ви повинні вгадати, подивіться
наша тема складається з двох слів, ваше
завдання — розшифрувати їх із зображень,
подивіться на  картинки, що може
бути першим словом, що спільного у цих
зображень чи пошта сигналізує вогонь
ієрогліфи
що це здається найдавнішим
засобом передачі інформації насправді
ми говоримо про спілкування і
що
це наступне, ви абсолютно праві, тобто
про технології, і тому сьогодні ми
говоримо про комунікаційні технології,
що таке комунікаційні технології,
це відноситься до всіх інструментів,
які використовуються для надсилання та обробки
інформації, що вони таке телефон,
телебачення, блоги, відеоблоги, багато соціальних
платформ, як-от Twitter Instagram pitama
так комунікаційні технології, які  це
те, чим ми користувалися щодня, і це
тема для сьогоднішнього уроку, комунікаційні
технології пройшли довгий шлях з
тих пір  більшість азбуки Морзе має
суть,
ви абсолютно праві,
це, як сказала Букка Марта, сьогодні
є чотири типи комунікаційних
технологій, подивіться на них
телебачення, чи можете ви впізнати,
що це однозначно телефонне радіо
в Інтернеті та нижче
існує тимчасова лінія, займіть п’ять секунд,
не більше, і помістіть ці винаходи
в часову лінію від найстарішого тут
до найновішого, готові п’ять секунд, щоб
подумати, в якому хронологічному порядку вони
були винайдені. Виконайте, давайте перевіримо, що, на
вашу думку, було винайдено спочатку, безперечно,
що  це телефон, тому давайте почитаємо про
нього. Засоби вербального спілкування зробили
революцію за допомогою телефону, який був
винайдений у 1876 році. Відстань більше не була
перешкодою, і люди могли
спілкуватися один з одним з будь-якої точки
світу давайте подивимося на деякі
фрази перешкодою  перешкода Перріш Кола
відстань не була перешкодою серед туманності
Перріш Коделл перешкода повторюй слова
за мною перешкода ще раз перешкода
гарна робота
Parrish coda англійською перешкода правильно
ви
ми в змозі люди були в змозі moly small так
може зайти в глухий кут просто або добре або
змогли зробити щось приємне давайте
перейдемо до другої конвенції давайте
перевіримо радіо правильно ви можете
давайте прочитаємо текст про  Через 20 років після того,
як телефонне спілкування за допомогою
радіо увійшло в гру радіо, яке використовується
для охоплення великої аудиторії, а не
лише однієї людини на іншому кінці
телефону, давайте зосередимося на фразах, які вступили
в гру.
слова
з'явилося радіо з'явилося радіо увійшло в
гру
повторіть фразу радіо увійшло в гру увійшло
в гру гарна робота і гарна фраза
зверніть увагу на слово, щоб
досягти привітання благодійність у нашому випадку
це охопити широку аудиторію, якщо
буддисти відкриються  велика громадськість, щоб
охопити широку аудиторію, давайте скажемо разом,
щоб охопити широку аудиторію, добре попрацюйте
значення слова протистояти проти,
що, на вашу думку, воно означає тут
порівнюється телефон порівнюється з
радіо добре, тому не про TiVo проти
повторити слово проти
чогось проти чогось не pro - vamos протистоїть
чомусь гарній роботі, більшою мірою
певною згадкою було телебачення правильно,
якусь інформацію важко описати,
використовуючи лише слова,
тому в  Винайдено телебачення 1926 року, воно
надає глядачам найкраще з обох
світів інформацію та візуальні елементи, які
супроводжують його, які фрази вам сподобалися
тут, зверніть увагу на цю найкраще
з обох світів найкраще з обох світів
давайте разом скажемо найкраще з обох
світів, які
добре в  українська у нас є еквівалент
pod vena para waha найкраще з обох
світів скажімо разом найкраще з
обох світів хороша робота давайте рухаємося далі,
а найновіший це Інтернет всі
види комунікаційних технологій
успішно поєднуються в Інтернеті він
почав свій початок більше  ніж 50 років тому, а
зараз забезпечує найбільше відображення
інформаційних та комунікаційних джерел,
відомих людині, давайте подивимося тут
t фраза найбільший дисплей
найбільший дисплей правильно все на
дисплеї дізнайтеся, як щодо ваших часових шкал,
чи виглядали вони так із
телефоном, радіо, телебаченням та
Інтернетом.
Тепер ваше завдання — завершити ці
речення інформацією з
тексту pay  зверніть увагу на перше, що
щось було винайдено в тому, що може бути
тут у тому році, і інша фраза:
це використовується для чого це було винайдено
добре,
п'ять секунд прогляньте текст,
знайдіть відповідну інформацію, щоб
заповнити пропуски, готові, давайте перевіримо  перший з них
- це телефон, скажімо, телефон
був винайдений в Оттаві в
1876 році, і він використовується для того, щоб
дозволити людям спілкуватися один з одним з
будь-якої точки світу, щоб увімкнути, щоб
люди могли ввімкнути його наступне
, про що йдеться  радіо, тож давайте покладемо сюди
радіо було винайдено, чи ви добре з
математикою, давайте порахуємо 20 років після 1876 року,
коли радіо було винайдено у 1896 році, і
воно звикло охоплювати широку аудиторію
добре, що наступне телебачення було винайдено в
1926 році, і воно використовується, щоб надати
глядачам найкращу
інформацію та візуальні зображення, які супроводжують його,
а останнє – Інтернет, що
ми можемо сказати про Інтернет Інтернет
був винайдений понад п’ятдесят років
тому право
і друге речення використовується для
того, що для того, щоб забезпечити
відображення інформаційних та комунікаційних джерел,
тепер подивившись на ці речення, яка
граматика, чи ви впізнали це правильно,
ви пасивний залог, і
це граматика нашого підрозділу  на цих уроках
ми будемо говорити та досліджувати
пасивний залог, що ви про нього пам’ятаєте,
ми оновимо інформацію, яку ви
знаєте, і додамо трохи більше готового
стійкого
так, тож ось три речення і
три правила, ваше завдання — виконати
правила  зі словами з поля та
зверніться до речень, щоб отримати
інформацію одна хвилина зробити це зроблено давайте
перевіримо це перше правило ми використовуємо
пасивний пасив the person or th  те, що
викликає дію, невідоме або
неважливе, тому особа, яка виконує,
невідома, ми не знали, хто це зробив
насправді, це не дуже важливо, щоб вони
виконували правильно, що
важливіше, насправді дія чи
продукт зробили це другим правилом, коли  ми
включаємо хто або що зробив дію, яку ми
використовуємо, визначено, ким ким була
чи зроблена дія та без місця ми утворюємо
пасив з правильною формою to be,
а потім дієприкметником минулого дієслова
насправді дає нам третє правило
формула пасивного залогу
давайте подивимося, щоб зробити пасивний залог, нам потрібні два
дієслова дієслово to be у його формах і
дієприкметник минулого часу дієслова минулого часу
як його зробити ми беремо
дієслово та додаємо або Edie, якщо дієслово
правильне  або нам знадобиться третя форма,
якщо це неправильне дієслово, і це те, що
ми можемо зробити пасивним, нам потрібно бути в
його формах правильного і минулого дієслова,
який виглядає або так, о, це
добре протягом усіх наших уроків цього разу.
m час від часу ми будемо посилатися на
формулу, тому давайте залишимо тут
гарний час для практики, подивіться на
картинку, чи можете ви впізнати, що це таке, якщо
немає заголовка, правильно ви є,
це Instagram, ви йдете
прочитати текст про Instagram, перш ніж читати
те,
що ви знаєте про Instagram, подумайте
щонайменше про три частини інформації
три ідеї Instagram подумайте про це п'ять
секунд отримати зараз прочитайте текст і перевірте
спробуйте знайти ці джерела натхнення
, можливо, щось інше
проігноруйте  прогалини дуже
добре, тож що ви знайшли про
Instagram, давайте відповімо на три запитання,
перш за все, що таке Instagram
Instagram — це програма чи
програма, яка програма для обміну
фотографіями та відео. Гарне
запитання номер два, що таке тег, знайдіть
цей фрагмент  інформація в тексті на
тегу – це слово або фраза на фотографії,
право ви перебуваєте, і питання номер три,
як люди голосують в Instagram, як
вони голосують за весь пакет, натиснувши «
подобається»  супер цього разу давайте спочатку подумаємо про
пропуски та дієслова, які слід поставити
в ці пропуски, давайте подивимося
на дієслова, які бабуся ви можете знайти
тут що це читати ви
пасивний залог давайте подумаємо про
теперішній час у минулому майбутньому, який це  може допомогти
нам, так, ми бачимо перше дієслово в
кожній фразі є тільки це, тому ми
говоримо про справжній простий пасив
, ось як це може виглядати так, ці
мережі, щоб показати, що воно наявне просто,
і нам потрібні ці дієслова, щоб показати  що
це пасивний залог так, як це може допомогти
нам, коли вибрати, коли вибрати,
дуже легко запам'ятати,
якщо тема є однією, яку ми зустрінемо, чи
можете ви прочитати її,
якщо ми використовуємо її, добре, коли
ми будемо використовувати багато чогось із множини
готові заповнити пропуски давайте зробимо
це проглянемо та заповніть пропуски
правильними дієсловами
[Музика]
готові перевірити добре
давайте зробимо це таким чином переглянемо і
ми прочитаємо весь текст отримати давайте
прочитаємо про Instagram  Інстаграм є
онлайн  додаток для обміну фотографіями та відео,
який належить Facebook, це означає,
що Facebook належить Instagram, а
Instagram належить Facebook. У 2012 році це
коштувало сайту соціальної мережі 1
мільярд доларів, але зараз
вважається, що додаток коштує всіх цих двадцяти
мільярдів  доларів кажуть, подивіться на це
дієслово. Вважається, що варто спробувати,
це хот-
доггер, тревінська вечірка.
додаток використовується людьми повторюйте
фразу програмою користується багато людей
отримати наступну Oba 60 мільйонів фотографій
публікуються щодня, і слово-фраза
часто додається на фото, утримуйте тег,
тому перший проміжок був незрозумілим, чому
тому  мова йде про фотографії у множині
правих фотографій. Фотографії публікуються
повторюйте фразу. Фотографії поширюються добре,
а проміжок номер 5 часто додається легко,
тому що потрібно підняти слово або F,
це отримати, а
останні люди часто голосують за інших  фотографії, які
їм подобаються, клацнувши, як і більше 10 000
лайків, щодня отримують фотографії в
Instagram, тому дані означають множину,
тому що світло у множині
добре, давайте підсумуємо ці етапи, які ми
розглянули, працюючи над цим завданням, поставити те,
що буде першим  ми звернули увагу
на малюнок і спробували передбачити
фрази, які ми могли б побачити в тексті,
правильно, що ви відчули, коли справді
знайшли ці фрази в тексті, радісно
вражений, добре, тоді ми звернули увагу
на дієслова в рамці ми проаналізували їх ми
з’ясували, яка граматика це правильний
пасив, який пасивний пасив теперішній простий
пасивний залог, що він дав нам під час
написання тексту, нам не знадобилося багато часу
, щоб знайти правильне дієслово чому, оскільки
ми знали, на що звернути увагу на
однину, оскільки was  множина за нашим
правом отримати що було наступним етапом ми
читаємо весь текст ми перевіряємо його читаємо
, щоб перевірити, чи все звучить
логічно, і останнім пишіть нову
інформацію, яку ви намагаєтеся розповісти, що ви
навчилися, щоб просто бути  готовий використовувати ці
слова та фрази, вказуючи комусь
іншому, щоб зробити їх активними,
насправді добре охопити всі ці
етапи, коли ви працюєте над бабусею, якщо це
не лише прості речення, так, але й
увесь текст, виконуючи цю граматику.  Це
буде дуже нудно, тому що це матиме
сенс, давайте спробуємо зробити те ж саме,
але в новому тексті, готовому до цього, отримаєте
що – спочатку проаналізуйте зображення
, подивіться, що може бути в тексті про те,
які слова ви можете побачити на зображенні
вірус і  попередження, тому текст може бути
про віруси, безумовно, яка задача
завершити текст про те, як працюють комп’ютерні
віруси мм-хм,
вся ідея тексту вже
дана у завданні, ми дізнаємося, як
добре працюють комп’ютерні віруси і
яке завдання зараз використовують  прості пасивні
форми дієслів так теперішній простий
пасив ще раз бути в теперішньому
простому має свої форми
М є наш і щоб зробити його світ пасивним
вам потрібно щось із цього або-або
право отримати зараз прочитати текст  і виконайте
завдання, розкрийте дужки з дієсловами,
аналізуйте цю тему один або багато, а
потім виберіть правильну форму дієслова.
давайте подивимося, чи є у вас така сама
ідея скажи подивіться на текст послухайте мене
і давайте прочитаємо разом готові
комп'ютерні віруси створюються не
комп'ютерами, вони написані
програмістами вірус завантажується
людьми часто в електронних листах іноді це
приховані в програмному забезпеченні віруси
видаляються спеціальним програмним забезпеченням на деяких комп'ютерах,
але якщо вірус не знайдено,
іноді його копії надсилаються іншим
людям електронною поштою, отримайте, що до наступного,
перегляньте текст ще раз і будьте
готові розповісти, що ви знаєте зараз  з
тексту про комп’ютерні віруси, хто їх створив,
як вони надсилаються і що робити,
як їх потрібно видалити, потратьте
хвилинку, перегляньте його і будьте готові переказати
[Музика]
перейдемо до заключної частини
нашого уроку
це  про ваше домашнє завдання цього
разу говорить ваше домашнє завдання
подивіться на нього.
Опишіть часову шкалу з чотирма
типами комунікаційних технологій,
використовуючи фрази з тексту, давайте підсумуємо,
які основні чотири типи
комунікаційних технологій вивчатимуть
сьогодні в порядку
з'явився перший гарний телефон потім
було винайдено радіо після цього телебачення
і останній Інтернет гарний,
тому ваше завдання - розповісти про
розвиток комунікаційних технологій,
але не забудьте використовувати пасивний голосовий
набір, ви чуєте дзвіночок, здається  ніби
наш урок закінчився, а технологія стремен-коп
є найкращою, коли об’єднує людей,
тож давайте слідкуємо за оновленнями і
до скорого побачення, до побачення
[Музика]